good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the CBO summit press
conference the three presidents will
first give their introductory remarks
and after that answer your questions
that you I first invite president
johannes of romania to take the phone
Peter thank you very much
Oona Sarah good evening it's a pleasure
for me to be here with you together
Daniel or she don't Laura well continue
in Romanian the 90 day Tata that's in
voice first of all I would like to tell
you how pleased I am but we are meeting
again here in CBO this is such an
important event for Romania and for the
entire European Union Romania is a
country that is now having the
presidency of the European Union and it
is a Member States that is fully
committed to the European project and
Romania has become today the very center
of the debate for the future on the
future of the European Union Europe has
come to Romania today historically
speaking this is the first meeting of
the European Council that Romania had
the opportunity to host the debates we
had today have already strengthened our
belief that we can write this history
together and the future of the European
Union
and we wished and now at the end I can
say that we succeeded in having a summit
of unity and of our determination to
continue on the European path in
achieving our unprecedented project of
prosperity peace and democracy a project
of stability both inside and towards the
outside our neighbors and I'm very happy
that it is from Romania that we managed
to launch a favourable message and
positive message of the member states
who all wish to strengthen the union
based on very clear principles and
values this message of our unity is also
perfectly consistent with the motto of
the European presidency which focused on
the principle of cohesion as a European
as a common European value when we took
on the man our mandate Romania wished to
pursue the project of having a more
cohesive Europe with more unity within
it among the member states also at the
regional and local levels but also at
the international level our unity and
cohesion in action turned us in what we
are today as a union a model of
democracy development and prosperity
today in CB we discussed about how we
want to pursue and where we want to take
the European project further we have
adopted a political declaration the CBU
declaration I hope it will stay as an
important benchmark landmark in the
history of the European Union and as we
had reached two years ago as we were
celebrating in Rome 60 years in since
the signature of the treaties I could
say that the most important message of
the spirit of CBO is reasserting our
wish and our desire to pursue the
European project and continue it ladies
and gentlemen
this is how we cast our message of
unitary action and political will on the
9th of May which is Europe's day I
congratulate you all
on our de Europe stay and I hope that
this positive message can reach as many
European citizens as possible and that
can in it make European citizens trust
more the force of the European Union I
am persuaded that the European Union
works in favor of the citizens our
common values and principles which are
reiterated in the Declaration were
reflected in the debates we had today
and they will shape the strategic
direction of the European Union in the
future strategic agenda which will be
adopted at the European Council meeting
in the month of June the global context
is constantly changing and therefore
Romania believes that the future
strategic agenda should provide common
understanding of our priority objectives
so that we can
provide for our union enough flexibility
and the required tools and resources in
order to reach its of its objectives I
think we need to provide it with and
require tools so that the European is
Union is stronger in the future and more
effective and that so that it can rely
on the Solidarity and cohesion of its
members in order to promote our common
European values this should be at the
very center of our future action we wish
for a strategic agenda that reflects an
ambitious vision for the future so that
it can bring very material benefits and
concrete benefits to its citizens and I
think in this respect the new strategic
agenda needs to focus on promoting
Europe of growth and convergence on
strengthening the single market
strengthening of the internal security
of the European Union and guaranteeing
an effective international action I
perhaps the most important thing is that
we wish to have a better communication a
more transparent one
and a more interactive one with the
European citizens thank you for your
attention
thank you and now Donald Tusk president
of the European Council thank you this
is what I received yesterday from Helmut
adamant and also a piece of advice how
to defend our European interests more
effectively and you know he's very
professional in in this merci helmet
tweaks a heads of the European
Parliament elections the leaders have
met in CBO to begin a discussion on the
EU's priorities for the coming years we
talked about about internal affairs as
well as global challenges bearing in
mind that's the world around us is
becoming increasingly changeable and
unpredictable without the discussion
will come in June when we will adopt the
youth priorities for the next five years
also known as the strategic agenda
without prejudging the outcome of this
debate it will also be influenced by the
European Parliament elections I can
state one thing with complete certainty
the leaders have categorically
demonstrated that they want to take full
political responsibility not only for
single events or challenges but for the
European Union as a whole but simply the
Member States and the democratically
elected leaders wants to actively shape
the way the EU functions and develops I
believe that such a way of thinking it's
important and above all desirable in
order to ensure the effective
functioning of our whole community this
is why I intend to maintain the spirit
of the discussion during the preparation
of the EU priority for the coming years
and in the process of nominating the new
EU leadership in this context I would
like to announce that just after the
European Parliament elections on the
28th of May I will call a meeting of all
28 EU leaders in order to start the
nomination process my intention is to
carry out the election of heads of EU
institutions in a swift smooth and
effective manner
naturally the process will follow the
rules set down in the treaties it should
reflect geographical balance as well as
demography so both large and small
countries are represented in the highest
positions in the EU to me the spirit of
the treaty is also important when it
comes to gender as well as political
balance of course it would be best if we
managed to reach consensus on all these
decisions but we have to be realistic
I will not shy away from putting these
decisions to the vote
if consensus proved difficult to achieve
the aim is simple we need effective
institutions and so we need Swift
decisions my intention is for the
European Council to nominate the new EU
leadership in June I call on everyone to
live up to their responsibility to make
this possible
today president ana flávia death also
informed the leaders of the Turkish
drilling activities within the exclusive
economic zone of Cyprus the European
Union stands united behind the Republic
of Cyprus and expects Turkey to respect
sovereign rights of the EU Member State
the European Council will continue to
follow these developments closely and
now I will move on to Romanian I would
like to thank president johannes for
organizing and hosting the EU summit
when we met back in January at the
beginning of the Romanian presidency I
have talked about Romania from my heart
because I am typically that you are a
remarkable country you organize an
exceptional summit and you can be proud
of the work you have done
as Europe is also proud of you all I
have simply fallen in love with CBO and
actually the whole of Europe is in love
with you thank you thank you and now
president Juncker of the European
Commission President gentlemen in
September 2017 in my state of Union
speech I suggested to Donald that we
should meet as European Council in Sibiu
we thought for the first meeting after
brexit but it's almost the same ready
why because I wanted you to fall in love
with this town and you responded to this
appeal in the next Secretary fashion
today's European Council it was one of
the easiest I've ever attended that's
because the romanian presidency in
particular kristen.clow scientists
prepared this council in the best
possible way and secondly because there
was no urgent decision to take this was
more a trial run for the European
Council of June this council nonetheless
showed that we were united that it
wasn't just a facade that there was
genuine unity and indeed over the last
five years we've succeeded in acting
together it's often said it's not
totally erroneous that the whole areas
in which the European Union has failed
to meet expectations
90% of Directors regulations have been
adopted unanimously out of 340 thousand
the European Union is not in crisis if
it's capable of adopting 90 percent of
the tax which are submitted to the Co
legislature it's true that more could
have been done if the institution's had
been capable of adopting these certain
proposals presented by the Commission in
2017 on the reform of the Asylum system
[Music]
we could then be even more even prouder
of our achievements but we've done some
key things
and we we shall try to achieve what
hasn't been achieved yet in the second
half this year of the European elections
which are of course very important
today
the spoken to be big on big and small
and small this slogan has been
translated into reality
so that's approach should be pursued
during the next Parliament's life we
often forget to take a close look at you
have been matters where would you do so
we'd realize that compared with 2014
unemployment has fallen investments has
revived investment is back to 2007
levels
deficits are fallen
[Music]
in 2018 deficits budget deficits were
four point six to nine point eight
percent come over six point two percent
in the worst year so things aren't
perfect by any means but they're not as
bad as all that
you impressed questions and we start
with the lady in the third row
Romanian television Ramona romesco
I have a question to all three
presidents in your fourth commitment in
the CBO declaration you mentioned
defending the common values of the Union
democracy and rule of law these are the
very values that you precedent to
encourage the Romanians when taking over
the presidency to defend justice held
onto Kadam defended for penalties in
Sevilla and since its accession Romania
has received many warnings from its
European partners in this respect so
where would you place Romania now I
would like to remind you that on the day
of the European election we also have a
referendum on justice related topics do
you think we need further action in
order to defend these values in the
spirit of the civil declaration and if
yes which would be these measures thank
you I think that my guests are more
entitled to answer this question
Donald jean-claude
we the level man yes
Romania does deserve particular
attention that's something we'll be
doing in the coming
days and weeks apart from that you've
got to remember the doctor now 1750
infringement procedures have been
initiated this is the number of
infringement procedures which haven't
yet been fully decided upon
so generally and on average 500
infringement procedures against Member
States were introduced by the Commission
which means
[Music]
but
the rule of law must apply to everybody
at times and we will continue in this
way
thank you we proceed to the next
question
and I have the lady here in the second
row muna Sarah arena mana Rocky good
evening Elina menelik ii DG 24 question
to all presidents we talk more and more
now reports
Hodari spoon Uncas I was saying that in
fact we we heard about the idea of
having a new commissioner who would be
in charge of the rule of law there are
some European leaders supporting the
idea so can could we have such a
portfolio in the future European
Commission and if yes
will there be clear criteria that all
Member States need to observe in this
respect and potential sanctions if the
criteria are not observed I understand
you're addressing me as if I were my
successor but I'm not going to be my
successor
monitoring of the state of through flaw
is organized in exemplary fashion
because it's vice-president the first
vice person of the Commission mr.
Timmons who deals with this for the
greatest pleasure of some and the
distress of others just from Newmarket
today it was obvious that for all of us
maybe almost all of the rule of law is
the essence of our political activity
and there will be also in the center of
the attention in our future documents
including strategy the agenda no doubt
and there is no Europe without rule of
law this is not because of some
ideological you know doctrine so no this
is this is the the quintessence of of
Europe as a political entity and and
it's not my role to
to intervene in some internal issues
here in Romania but with my own personal
experience I know one thing that if you
are ready to defend the idea of rule of
law then you can be optimistic but only
then it's we are it's not it's not only
the problem in some member stages we can
unfortunately we can we can talk today
about a very dangerous trend in global
politics and this desire in some
governments to reduce the system here
this is something visible not only in
Europe and this is why everything almost
everything is in your hands if if people
if people don't care about rule of law
then government will will give up
and this we are the earth guarantee that
this idea of rule of law will survive in
Europe and I have one thing to say the
principle of the rule of law is the very
foundation of the European values I wish
for the rule of law in Romania and the
Romanians also wish for it we have a few
politicians who do not want it here but
the decisions is in the Romanian
citizens hands and we'll have elections
now Europe elections for the European
Parliament the referee
presidential elections and will have a
clear answer from our citizens and I can
hardly wait for it and if we need a
Commissioner with such a portfolio then
the future President of the European
Commission will decide if such a post of
Commissioner will exist or whether the
portfolio will be delegated to one of
the commissioners see many hands but I
believe that the next one was for the
floor is the gentleman to our left in
the six remaining statement a question
for president tusk as you look David her
Xandra the political Europe as you look
ahead to the deliberations over future
in leadership positions how important is
it to you that there be someone from
these to follow in your footsteps or is
it maybe the turn of the North to have a
chance at a top job as I mentioned we
have a in fact a very formal not only
political obligation to respect this
so-called geographical balance this is
this is a very clear point in our also
in our treaty and it's not only about
the geography of God but about the
common feeling that neutral and brief
enough to protect smaller countries or
weaker countries or new countries I
think that like jean-claude because it
was for both of us it was a it was a
very serious obligation to protect the
weak against against super powers when
when they need was obvious you know it's
in fact this is also for me like rule of
law also this rule I mean to protect
weaker
people or Member States or it's also the
essence the essence of Europe and just
walking about because two days ago or
three days ago I've met with our
European representation of the European
business and trade unions and the
message from them was absolutely clear
the highest priority for the European
trade unions and European business is
also rule of law we have no chance to
protect workers to execute the trade
unions rights and obligations we can't
protect business and and high standards
when it comes to business without rule
of law it's not an ideological
discussion it's not because of some you
know differences between governments or
it is not an onion intellectual or moral
challenge this is a real question for
millions of people also businesses and
workers and it must be clear for
thank you I'll take one last question
yes you're a gentleman in the fourth
week sanics I thank you very much Alex
speaking from a journal small supplies I
I just had a question for you mr. Tuscan
mr. Juncker about climate change there's
a lot of young people who are very
scared about their future and they
protest every at the end of every week
in so many cities across Europe you
haven't mentioned climate change in
talking about the future of Europe here
on the podium today now I know that
eight countries we know that eight
countries have are looking for zero net
emissions by 2050 and are asking for
more ambition I was just asking both of
you is whether you feel like the EU
member-states are ready to unify around
this issue or do you think that there's
some Member States that are just not
ready to go as far as let's say for
example these two eight member states
and obviously I'm thinking of Germany an
important auto industry and maybe even
Poland you know with the issue around
coal thank you very much
I do think that the European you is
right by drawing with their means and
the instruments our collective attention
to what is one the risk to be the
reality of two more so I'm feel a lot of
sympathy for what the young people in
you about do I I was during decades
complaining about the fact that the
young the youngest youngest Europeans
were no longer in the street when I was
young I was in the street all the time
Saturday afternoon and Sunday morning
but this has this has change we had Nam
Pinochet Spain Portugal so I like the
fact that younger people in Europe have
decided to take their fate in their own
hands and to invite leaders to do what
has to be done I have carefully studied
this latter of seven or eight nano
states
inserting in the landscape a new target
for 2050 I agree with that but I have to
say that we have a first target to be
meted in 2030 so let's concentrate on
immediate and urgent actions let's not
try to escape to our responsibility by
fixing a target long time after the
active time we are spending in policy in
politics young generation is much more
united on this then then the Member
States the truth is that nothing has
changed when it comes to device and and
different opinion about this what if you
not only for me if this is very fresh
and energetic pressure and I think
because I was also prominent in I know
how sensitive politicians are when comes
to protest and and the massive movement
and I think that now we can see
something like you know a second
revolution when comes to not only
climate change
violent more MORE not only in in climate
contact but also plastic and also on
oceans oceans and and other things I am
absolutely sure that there's no future
for politicians without this sensitivity
and imagination maybe not if not
tomorrow for sure
the day after tomorrow they will lose
okay that was a good finish thank you
very much
[Music]
only public and now candidacy
[Music]
but more power than today diffuser the
whole landscape of office